let's talk about Amazon you might have
seen the headlines over the weekend
Amazon paid no taxes federally on eleven
point two billion dollars in profits in
2018 in fact Amazon actually had a
negative federal tax rate last year
Amazon receiving a refund of a hundred
and twenty nine million dollars last
year which works out to a negative tax
rate now consider that the poorest 20
percent of American households paid 1.5
percent federal tax on average a couple
of years ago okay
Amazon with eleven billion dollars in
profits paid a negative one percent tax
rate how does Amazon respond to requests
for comment about this they say what
every single one of these companies says
which is we paid all of the taxes that
we are legally required to pay which of
course isn't the issue the issue is why
is it that the law allows for this to
take place and the answer is the
corporate lobbying industrial complex
the way that this happens because you
might say wait David the the corporate
tax rate was thirty five percent and
then Donald Trump dropped it to twenty
one percent how is it that Amazon paid
minus one percent taxes it doesn't make
sense well there's a couple different
reasons number one there is a massive
tax break that is given out for
executive stock options that saved
Amazon about half of all the taxes that
they would normally pay and then there's
a whole bunch of unspecified tax credits
of all kinds which are just like classic
lobbyist crony handouts and all of these
mechanisms were lobbied for by corporate
lobbyists we are a corporate sock recei
as I have been telling you so let's talk
about reactions to this first you have
some people on the right who are sort of
claiming to be angry about this even
though they seem to believe that
corporations having tax cuts is good for
the economy one example is that guy
charlie
jerk from Turning Point USA he's been
using the Amazon story just to get
clicks check out his double standard
like within hours he tweeted Alexandria
Cassio Cortez has done more damage to
her community than any representative in
recent memory
she killed a multi-billion dollar
investment meaning Amazon from coming to
New York and with it 25,000 middle-class
jobs she is a perfect socialist saying
Amazon is good and AOC shouldn't have
lobbied against it coming to Newt to New
York City and then just hours later
charlie Kirk criticizing Amazon for
paying zero in federal taxes despite 11
billion in earnings and saying if this
is cronyism so is Amazon good or bad
charlie because that entire New York
City headquarters was going to be a huge
tax hand out to them but he's saying AOC
did the wrong thing by preventing them
from coming to New York City totally
incoherent okay these people on the
right that are playing games with this
simply shouldn't be part of the
discussion the real question here is one
of supply side versus demand side okay
if you are given huge corporate tax
breaks for executive stock options that
encourages very specific behaviors
number one it encourages the company
Amazon to give more money to executives
rather than to give money to regular
workers this increases inequality this
shifts the tax burden away from
corporations and from executives and it
shifts it towards in proportion regular
workers
that's called supply-side economics or
trickle-down economics the idea that if
we have the corporation pay less tax and
we give the richest people at our
company more money that that is going to
magically trickle down and be good for
everybody a rising tide lifts all boats
sort of thing it's it's wrong I mean
it's just been widely debunked there is
no serious economic evidence supporting
that the counter-argument is hey we
should get rid of these tax breaks and
these deductions and these credits that
would then shift the burden to those who
can most afford it
and least need the additional money
which they would disproportionately
stick in a bank account anyway not
stimulating the economy the corporation
for example that profited to the tune of
11 billion dollars and the executives
should be bearing more of the tax burden
the individual workers often working at
Amazon under not great conditions they
should get more money which they would
likely spend in the economy and that
would be much better for the economic
ecosystem at large now this is not
likely to change soon even a lot of
Democrats don't have as a top priority
changing these kinds of deductions
exemptions and loopholes one idea that's
a very very interesting idea is a
minimum tax for corporations with
individuals there is something called
the alternative minimum tax which means
if you made a million dollars for
example and you can come up with
$900,000 in deductions which will get
you down to only paying taxes on
$100,000 you're not allowed to do that
because of something called the
alternative minimum tax which says it
doesn't matter how many deductions you
could take if this is your income there
is some minimum amount of tax that you
have to pay people like Donald Trump for
example a lot of the taxes that he does
pay are because of the alternative
minimum tax so the idea is an
alternative minimum tax for corporations
if a corporation has the revenues and
profits that Amazon has even if they
could put together cobble together
enough deductions and tax breaks and
credits to end up paying zero an
alternative or a corporate minimum tax
would force them to pay some minimum
level of tax which would make a really
big difference to the the programs that
could be funded out of those taxes it's
an idea
good luck getting Democrats and
Republicans to act together to actually
make that happen there are other ways
but I'm not going to go into them now it
should probably be a segment on its own
send me your thoughts
where
not only on so there's kind of two
issues here issue number one is what
should the taxation policy be around
corporations issue number two is this
sort of incoherence about Amazon from
the right on the one hand they want low
corporate taxes on the other hand many
of them are angry with Amazon because
Jeff Bezos doesn't like Donald Trump but
on the other hand they also are mad with
mad at Alexandria Ocasio Cortez because
she is perceived to have been one of the
factors that is now leading to Amazon
not building their second headquarters
in New York City send me your thoughts
about the hypocrisy send me your
thoughts about the double standards but
also send me your thoughts about what
tax policy should be towards these
massive corporations make sure you're
following me on instagram at david
pakman follow the show there as well at
David Pakman show
coming up after the break I will speak
about what is the inevitable future of
the relationship between humans and work
and what we consider normal jobs
Ellen shell joins me next today's
program is sponsored in part by spresso
bucks who are offering everybody in our
audience a bunch of really cool free
stuff espresso box is a company based in
New York City and they are going to make
your life a lot easier and save you
money when it comes to keeping up with
men's fashion because when you sign up
for spreads about you'll get a totally
new box sent to your door every month
with five or six hand-picked accessories
and pieces of clothing you'll get things
like really stylish socks neckties
high-end sunglasses wallets watches
bracelets high-quality pens and hair
combs the list goes on but it's all
really nice stuff must-haves for any guy
who's wanting to update his wardrobe I
got some really cool stuff in my
espresso box including a money clip as
well as a very nice pocket square and
some really good-looking socks all of
which are very very cool thus preserve
our subscription is just 25 bucks a
month but you definitely come out ahead
because every box every single month is
guaranteed
have items with a combined value of over
$100 so they make it easy to keep your
outfits fresh but you're also getting a
lot of bang for your buck and it makes a
really great gift for a guy in your life
everyone in our audience can get one
month totally free when you click the
link underneath this video and use the
promo code Pakman that's PA que ma n